hey what's up i'm alicia malone for
fandango movie clips and here are five
reasons to be excited for the tribeca
film festival
let's start with a crime thriller which
sounds absolutely fascinating called
mojave it stars garrett headland as a
hollywood director who heads out to the
desert for some solitude armed with a
knife and some vodka and oscar isaac who
plays the homicidal drifter he comes
across who has a rifle and calls himself
the devil this movie is written and
directed by william monahan who is the
brilliant screenwriter behind the
departed now to a documentary which had
a lot of buzz at the sundance film
festival called kurt cobain montage of
heck this is the first documentary about
kurt cobain to be completely supported
by his family who gave rare home videos
and interviews for the documentary it's
produced by his daughter francis bean
cobain and courtney love will be in
attendance for a special q a all eyes
will be on arnold schwarzenegger in his
dramatic role in the zombie film maggie
where he plays a father who is trying to
save his daughter from a zombie illness
and i think you can guess what happens
next this movie was supposed to play at
the toronto film festival but got pulled
after lionsgate snapped up the rights so
this is your first chance to see arnie
in his single-tier dramatic role i may
have promised your mother that will
protect you
alongside the films tribeca is hosting
some great panel discussions called
tribeca talks director series carrie
fukunaga brad bird christopher nolan and
george lucas will all be speaking on
separate panels hosted by comedians and
other directors the hottest ticket will
be for george lucas being interviewed by
self-confessed geek and super sharp
comedian stephen colbert and one special
event sure to get film buffs excited is
the closing night film a special 25th
anniversary screening of good fellas
never rain on your friends
and always keep your mouth shut where
better to do it than at the tribeca film
festival where one of its founders is
goodfellas star robert de niro he will
be there as well as some other cast
members hopefully mr scorsese all in a
special q a hosted by jon stewart so
there you have it those are our five
reasons to be excited for the tribeca
film festival for fandango movie clips
i'm alicia malone bye
you